[Música]
es un viaje que nadie quería hacer y que
por fin ha terminado para estos
refugiados ucranianos es el comienzo de
una nueva vida en berlín pero los
recuerdos de su hogar pesan en sus
corazones
siempre pregunta por su padre
y está preguntando
dónde está su padre y cuándo puede verlo
y que le puede decir
no lo sé
pero antes de llegar a europa occidental
primero deben salir de ucrania y pasar
por los países vecinos
en polonia el pianista david mate lo
levantó el ánimo de los refugiados y
tocó we are the champions de queen con
una mujer que dijo no haber dormido en
tres días
otros huyeron a eslovaquia con solo lo
que podían llevar y sus posesiones más
preciadas
mis amigos están asustados y tienen
miedo de que la artillería disparé por
todas partes sin quiebre la unión
europea decidió el jueves por la noche
conceder a todos los ucranianos que
huyen del conflicto permisos temporales
de protección y residencia evitando así
las trabas burocráticas para buscar
asilo es la primera vez que el bloque
toma una medida de este tipo pero hay
una advertencia importante los
extranjeros que habían estado viviendo
en ucrania no recibirán esas mismas
protecciones la medida llega después de
que se informara de que personas
afrodescendientes que huían de la guerra
habían sido rechazadas por guardias
fronterizos en el paso de ucrania a
polonia lado no advierte que más de 10
millones de personas podrían verse
desplazadas si la violencia continúa